this morning one American is waking up
as the first person ever to trek across
Antarctica alone and without any help
Colin O'Brady finished the daunting
journey across the world's coldest and
driest continent yesterday he battled
frigid temperatures whiteout conditions
and roaring winds for more than 900
miles the feat was a dream come true for
an adventurer athlete whose life goal is
to show others that sometimes you can
achieve the impossible on November 3rd a
Russian cargo plane dropped off 33
year-old Colin O'Brady at the edge of
nowhere he was alone except for 400
pounds of food and equipment in
Antarctica a place so cold water freezes
in midair O'Brady had a mission to
become the first person to trek across
Antarctica alone and without health he
also had real-time competition British
Army captain Lewis Rudd a more
experienced athlete with the same dream
joined him at the starting line the two
men took off on different paths O'Brady
walked almost 20 miles and 12 hours a
day in 90 minute increments stopping to
sleep in a tent consume 8,000 calories a
day call his wife and post his progress
on social media journalist Adam Skolnick
chronicled the race and spoke to O'Brady
by phone during his journey on Christmas
morning he wakes up and he decides to go
32 straight hours 77.54 miles all in one
shot it was the final stretch O'Brady
finished first 54 days after he began
traveling 932 miles in all he was really
humbled he's really happy for it to be
over
Oh Brady hasn't always been quick on his
feet ten years ago his legs were badly
burned in a fire in Thailand doctors
told him he probably wouldn't walk
normally again but he did learn to walk
again then run before going on to win
the Chicago triathlon 18 months after
his accident in 2016 he became the
fastest person to summit the tallest
peaks on each of the seven continents
first a year before embarking on his
Antarctic journey Oh Brady gave this TED
talk about what he's learned as an
adventure athlete achievement is simply
for those who never quit it is for those
who put the most steps in front of the
others
quite literally sort of Oh Brady is not
rushing home just yet he'll wait for
Rudd to finish the race which should
take another day or two and then both
men will leave Antarctica together just
like the journey began and this is great
so you wonder how far that really is
it's like walking from DC to Tampa so
think about that and Arctica conditions
what's sportsmanship for him to wait for
the other person to get to the finish
line to leave together but he wasn't
just in a race against him he was a race
in a race against himself it's so
inspiring
teamwork competition also puts all of
our commutes home for the holidays
introspect very much so by the way the
last person to try this before them last
year they quit the year before someone
died trying to do this so they knew the
risks going into this certain